>> So, these are the four steps that will help us
complete the task of Dorm Room Debbie going from being hungry,
to being satisfied with pizza. It's important that we start with
these high level steps, before we start thinking about any of
the details. As part of the wire framing process, we need
to remind ourself of our persona and their Use Cases. So
her Use Cases are, she's up late, and she wants pizza
right away. Or, it's been a long week, and she wants
to try something new and fun.
>> Now this is a mobile app so, regardless
of who the user is, we cannot the violate
the following mobile user constraints, such as limited data
and battery life, handedness, divided attention, and so on.
>> And the next step is our Feature List. The feature list
is driven by Dorm-Room Debbie's attributes and her use cases. Let's not
focus too much on how we're going to put these features in our
application just yet. But let's just look at them in a list.
>> Look
below in the instructor notes and you'll find a link to this prezi. Open
it up in the web browser and follow along for the rest of lesson.
>> And now we're going to dig a little bit deeper into the flow
of our app. So, we showed you the four high level steps, that we
need to go through to complete the task of Debbie going from hungry,
to being satisfied. Now let's jump into the flow for each of these steps.
>> So, here's step one. This is the screen that
a user sees when they first enter the application. And honestly,
there's only one of three things they could do. They can
build a brand new pizza, if they've never used the application before.
Or they can re-order a previous pizza, if they've used this app
before. And if they have a pizza that's already in order, they
can check its order status. So in order to begin we will
pick the first option, which is they're going to build a new pizza.
Step two is where the user is going to configure their pizza, and
make sure that it's exactly what they want by choosing the size,
the crust, the toppings side orders and so on. Now, if they don't want to
actually build the pizza, they can view
the daily specials and pick one of those.
>> And the third step is where they checkout and pay. If the user hasn't
already signed in, they'll do so here.
If they've already saved their payment and delivery
information, they can easily just skip through
those steps or they can enter it in.
Then they place their order. So if you've
used this application before, step three will be
really fast. All you have to do is click,
Place your Order. Once Debbie's placed her order, she'll
see the order status. And if she has a
question about her order, she can contact her driver.
>> So let's say that Debbie has placed an order for a pizza already,
that was a couple of days ago. She like the pizza. She likes the app.
She came back in. And now she wants to re-order the same thing again. This
is where she would select option two,
which is re-order a previous pizza. This flow
was actually really, really simple. She's probably signed in already.
If she hasn't, then she will be asked to sign
in. This might seem a little bit strange, but consider
the possibility that Debbie has more than one phone, or more
than Android device. She can have a tablet, multiple phones
and so on. Anyway, so if she signed in, then she'll
be able to see all the order history for previous
orders. And then select one, and place an order for you.
>> Now we're back to step three, which is check out pay. Because she's
already signed in, all she'll have to press is
Place order. And step four will be the same.